[Música]
este domingo terminó la conferencia de
Munich la reunión es de tres días en la
que los líderes mundiales se trazan las
políticas de seguridad y discuten los
temas que más les preocupan esta
conferencia nació en el 63 en tiempos de
la guerra fría y fue en su época el
espacio en el que la otan hablaba de
cómo contrarrestar el poder de la unión
soviética este año el gran ausente fue
Rusia mientras que la guerra en Ucrania
fue el tema central de la discusión para
analizar lo que ocurrió en Múnich nos
acompaña Diana Luna ella es analista
internacional asesora política y también
especialista en Alemania Muchísimas
gracias Diana por estar con nosotros
Muchas gracias Ángela y la primera
pregunta sobre uno de los temas más
relevantes del fin de semana la
vicepresidenta de Estados Unidos kamala
Harris usó la conferencia para anunciar
que Estados Unidos determinó formalmente
que Rusia cometió crímenes contra la
humanidad ahora esta declaratoria lleva
Estados Unidos a alguna acción
específica o cuál es el simbolismo que
carga
lismo que carga es que cualquier plan a
futuro que que busque presentar china
muy en específico el plan para La Paz Va
a tener poca legitimación porque
recordemos que china ha sido uno de los
pocos países que no ha condenado la
guerra en Ucrania y
hemos visto hay reportes que indican que
china podría estar suministrando armas
letales a Rusia en los siguientes
semanas y entonces
el esta información nos hace ver que
Estados Unidos no va a dejar esto así
sino que en caso de que china suministre
armas letales habrá consecuencias
severas
bueno justamente usted se adelanta al
otro gran tema de la Cumbre del fin de
semana y es las interacciones entre
Estados Unidos y china en una entrevista
para una cadena estadounidense el
secretario de estado Anthony blinquen
dijo que Estados Unidos estaba muy
preocupado por esta supuesta
consideración de China de brindar apoyo
letal a Rusia y sobre esto habló en
Múnich también con su homólogo chino en
una reunión que fue ampliamente cubierta
Por qué la nueva preocupación contra el
gobierno de Y qué municiones Se podrían
estar contemplando
Bueno
hay una gran preocupación
si bien la conferencia de seguridad se
respiró un aire de unidad entre los
aliados occidentales también se ha
quedado Se ha podido ver que
que china no sigue tomando una posición
neutral que por muchos es considerado no
es neutral sino es muy muy una posición
muy marcada del lado de Rusia
es urgente la ayuda a armamentista a
Ucrania y en este sentido por un lado
tenemos a los países occidentales que
buscan
surtir con mejor y más armamento a
Ucrania Pero por otro lado tenemos
reportes de que ucra de que china podría
estar enviando en algunas semanas sobre
todo hay que considerar que Rusia está
preparando una de las ofensivas más
fuertes como respuesta al armamento que
han enviado países occidentales en
especial europeos Alemania a Ucrania
Entonces en este sentido Rusia necesita
la ayuda armamentista de de China y se
habla no se tiene en concreto no se
tiene claro Qué tipo de armamento está
suministrando en ocasiones pasadas china
ha sido muy claro que está en contra de
una
escalada nuclear está en contra de que
esta guerra pueda tomar estos puede
llegar a ser una guerra nuclear sin
embargo es muy preocupante estos
reportes porque si bien sabemos Rusia
está preparando su ofensiva necesita de
armamento también Ucrania necesita al
momento Y esto es uno de los de los
resultados que da la conferencia que los
las los aliados occidentales se
comprometen a enviar mayor armamento de
China pero se habla de un posible
de hacer mano de un posible fondo de la
defensa europeo que ya existe pero en
donde podría llevarse a cabo un programa
más ambicioso claro
conferencia de seguridad por primera vez
en más de 20 años Rusia no recibió
invitación Irán tampoco fue convocado
por supuesto que tanto contribuye esto a
la Cumbre que es considerada como el
davos de la seguridad A que sea cada vez
más un reflejo de la visión únicamente
occidental
o no hay que considerar los
organizadores de la conferencia
decidieron claramente no invitar a la
delegación oficial rusa si bien la
oposición rusa estuvo representada y
hubo un panel en donde se habló acerca
de la del rol de la sociedad civil rusa
en este conflicto la decisión fue muy
clara no se invitaba a la delegación
oficial rusa ni a Irán porque sería
ofrecerles un escenario público para que
ellos puedan llevar a cabo y y y y
compartir su propaganda Entonces era muy
claro que eso no era el objetivo de la
conferencia de seguridad en este caso
mi lectura es que el objetivo de la
conferencia era
Buscar esta unidad no solo entre los
aliados de La nato claramente sino
también
Buscar
estrechar más Los lazos con el sur
global que aquellos países no alineados
muchos de ellos parte de países
latinoamericanos como Brasil que busque
no se no están alineados que no se
consideran que han tomado una posición y
de un lado ni del otro de la guerra
se busca lograr que aquello que esos
países se sientan más cercanos a los
aliados occidentales condenen no solo la
guerra claramente si no estén dispuestos
a tal vez a también a establecer
sanciones en contra de Rusia y aquí fue
muy interesante ver la participación de
la vicepresidenta de Colombia Marqués
tratando de de que no solo se hable de
una paz
sin armas sino también de una paz social
de disminuir la desigualdad Entonces el
objetivo claro era tratar de acercar a
aquellos países que se consideran no
alineados los que ellos les llaman el
sur global pero también
mostrarse más Unidos y creo que aquí es
importante Resaltar que aquellas
potencias medianas como Brasil Turquía
Indonesia son claves en ya que estamos
viendo como el mundo se está
conformando más en un mundo multipolar
en donde países como china como la como
Estados Unidos o entidades como la Unión
Europea o India tratan de de acercar
estos países anualiados para
que sus bloques sean más fuertes no solo
para términos geoestratégicos sino
también para términos de guerra Bueno
una tarea que hemos visto muy claramente
de parte de Estados Unidos buscando
restar influencia de Rusia en América
Latina como usted lo mencionaba hace un
momento Diana se nos quedamos ya sin
tiempo ese Diana Luna analista
internacional asesora política y
especialista en Alemania
Muchas gracias Ángela y a usted que
tenga buen día y a nuestros televidentes
que quedense con nosotros hacemos una
pausa de solo segundos y ya volvemos con
más
[Música]